Israeli forces have violently confronted
Palestinian worshipers near the Al-Aqsa
mosque compound in occupied East
Jerusalem they scuffled with women and
prevented young Palestinian men from
entering the mosque at least one
Palestinian man was arrested inside the
compound earlier hundreds of ultra
nationalist Israelis made an incursion
into the Al-Aqsa Courtyards let's go to
Paul Brennan and occupied East Jerusalem
Paul tell us what happened this morning
yeah it's important to contextualize
this the women that we see in that video
are members of a group called marabitat
and they are women who are pledged to
protect the Al-Aqsa mosque I saw the
woman with the pale leopard print scarf
and spectacles up here actually on
Wednesday making a social media video
pledging to protect the mosque so these
aren't members of the general public
these are women who are
demonstrating with those Israeli
soldiers and demanding access but the
reason why they were demonstrating with
the soldiers is because this weekend is
Rosh Hashanah the Israel the the Jewish
New Year and again as happens on so many
days Jewish far-right settlers and
nationalists have been escorted into the
area of the Al-Aqsa mosque it's called
an incursion because it's done without
the permission of the wac which is the
Jordanian Palestinian Group which
organizes would organize such visits and
it creates enormous tension and enormous
antagonism as well with those people who
are worshiping at the mosque and not the
mosque the arrest that we saw I think
most likely we haven't heard from the
police about this but the arrest on days
like today young men in their 20s and
30s are prevented are banned from
accessing the Moss because very often
it's the young men whose tempers get the
better of them and who confront these
Jewish Nationalist incursions and so
they are banned so I suspect that the
young man that we saw being arrested was
one of those who'd perhaps slipped
through the net and the police were
taking him away but there is perspective
I mean on the one hand you could say the
police are doing a very good job of
keeping the peace but on the other hand
from the suddenly the Palestinian
perspective you can say that they are
essentially threatening the status quo
by facilitating these visits by Jewish
settlers onto this holy site now Paul
Brennan reporting from occupied East
Jerusalem thank you very much